just when you felt fallout 4 is
encumbrance system was frustrating the
Fez de says shut up and doubles down on
it this new and improved difficulty
setting called survival mode is open
beta on Steam and it is absolutely
brutal your inventory gets cut in half
hunger thirst and fatigue are a constant
worry you take way more damage
mo and stimpaks have weights no more
fast travels and the real kicker the
only way to save your game is by
sleeping in a bed but why why would
anyone want to play like this well the
co survival mode at its core it's how
fallout 4 should be played well at least
some of the features feel that way the
moan forces you to quit all of those bad
hoarding habits completely wiping the
way you manage inventory the first thing
you'll do in survival mode drop
everything what in how much you think
you can carry goes out the window you
never thought twice about lugging around
ammo and stimpaks
now you will take a once weightless mini
nuke for example they now weigh 12
pounds and that's just one weapon
package after weighing the perks of
countless weapon types and tossing out
your babies you finish your arsenal
spring cleaning and come to a haunting
realization I'm carrying two weapons
that dwindling down is due to the
wellness factors that now run your life
if you don't eat drink and sleep your AP
meter fills up with red operating the
same way rads do with health in fact
you'll drink clean water more than you
use stimpacks and now that stimpacks
waypoint 1 pounds 127 you've stacked up
just drop to 10 of the 3 sleeping is not
as pressing as the others and now you're
already looking for beds constantly in
order to save conveniently there are
already tons of beds and mattresses
scattered around the world only you'll
need to sleep in a full size bed at some
point in order to completely eliminate
your fatigue because in survival mode
you're forced to take a hard look at
what you actually need in a typical
wasteland outing no longer are you
stuffing your face with every piece of
junk we find before over encumbrance
prevents you from fast travelling home
you pick up that one blueprint you're
trying to craft and you stick to the
materials and entails but over
encumbrance
really isn't the only reason why you're
crawling home there's a fear and running
out of clean water because drinking
dirty water leads to rads rads leach
taking rat aways and the thing is rat
aways and Kem's immediately make you
parched it's a vicious cycle that
formulates a fear of being stranded
slowly dying in the wasteland with your
health withering away along with your 30
minutes of progress and that fear is the
goddamn best part it pressures you to
plan ahead
up until survival mode you were looking
at a map littered with destinations now
it's filled with routes waypoints ending
with a safe settlement to not just
restock but relax take this run of mine
for instance after a night of inventory
prep I wake up at 1:00 a.m. to avoid
ending my run at night I drink water
from the pump I have breakfast I get in
my power armor because I'm a wuss and
then I hit the road with my companion
ADA who carries a fat man in emergency
supplies the plan is to tackle a
sidequest at the watering station do
some aluminium looting and then end at
Diamond City to restock it's a good plan
and it starts off fine keeping my
distance by sniping ignoring the
occasional squad of super mutants
finding plenty of beds to sleep at it's
a breeze then I find these sewers it's
not part of the plan but I got this no I
don't it's filled with ghouls five
minutes in I realize I'm out of clean
water so now I'm drinking sewage I run
out of ammo for both weapons so I'm
forced to pick up and use a pipe pistol
I haven't saved in 20 minutes and I'm
using a pipe pistol to survive I managed
to get out and I check into the dugout
in for the night I put 150 hours in
fallout 4 and I've never felt the panic
and sheer gravity of my actions for such
a long period of time it was awesome as
someone who had a pretty dull and
tedious experience towards the end of
the main campaign survival mode is a
breath of fresh air I wish was always
present it wasn't just the difficulty
that made it so enjoyable but the mode
gave so much more meaning to the content
already present in the game building
settlements and supply lines actually
makes sense
tagging specific routes using empty
bottles for water cooking food and
actually using mattresses you always run
into and let's be honest no one should
end the game with 130 stimpacks after
that's just dumb survival mode is in
beta and still needs to work out some
kinks such as your water dependency is
way too high and frequent crashes drove
me absolutely insane regardless for
those of you who found fallout 4 easy or
lacking survival mode is definitely
worth coming back to and with DLC down
the road I won't be playing it any other
way
so shall we about time to hit the road
understood please wait on